officers blocking protesters from a
police precinct during
new unrest in the city of seattle the
protests were mostly peaceful
just one day after chaotic clashes in
that city
seattle police releasing body camera
video of the saturday
riots officers say they were hit by
rocks water bottles explosives but never
these are peaceful
59 officers were injured remember in
that peaceful protest 47 people
were arrested this as portland oregon
sees its 60th straight night of
unrest rioters set off fireworks
overnight near the courthouse police
used tear gas apparently
to disperse the crowds as you can see
right there two people taken into
custody
after a shooting was reported just about
a block from the demonstrations one
person
was injured and moments ago several
police cars were found
burned in philadelphia no one was hurt
thank goodness no word yet on any
suspects
there that's right now chris christie
over the weekend was defending the
president for sending these federal
troops to different cities especially
portland he
sent those in to protect the federal
courthouse there listen to chris
christie the former governor of your
state steve new jersey
most americans george do not believe
that the riots that are happening in
portland and seattle
and in other places across the country
that are causing destruction and injury
and in some cases death
are acceptable mayors in those towns are
too politically
timid to address people who are defacing
and destroying their cities then the
president united states has to deal with
it
it's his responsibility as president if
the mayors are willing to walk away from
their own responsibility
not to support peaceful protests but to
stop
violent riots and uh it's good to see
somebody
stick up for the president over the
weekend because it's a federal
government
you can watch cities burn and say have
nothing to do with it or you can put
people actions say how can i help it
and then after 50 plus days they go the
problem is
those hundred those hundred
federal agents they came out to help
that's the problem
i think rational people know that's not
the problem also there's a worry
there's a worry that the feeling and the
push for racial justice
and police reform that everyone was on
to a degree the same
page with has devolved into a white
spectacle this according to an
n-c-double
and a double a-c-p spokesperson he says
not to denounce the overall presence of
white people at the protest
but this has become a white spectacle as
government buildings have been damaged
and objects have been hurled at law
enforcement
causing a distraction we welcome our
white brothers and sisters
but i must ask them to remain humbly
attuned to the opportunity of the moment
and to reflect on what their actions are
doing and if they're achieving the goal
for african americans so they might have
over corrected
with people that really don't know
what's going on they just want to get up
take part in the protest
right let's bring in arkansas gop center
uh tom cotton member of the senate armed
services committee
hey senator you had one person over the
weekend defend the president's action
because he decided not to sit on his
hands and watch water know 12
15 cities burn
well good morning guys morning uh the
president has to take
action to defend federal properties and
installations he ought not have to
local mayors and governors should defend
federal property the same way they
defend
private property of their own public
property but what you see
in portland is a systematic deliberate
and ongoing attack on the federal
courthouse and the federal building
of course the federal government has to
defend its own property
if a local local mayor will not if he
doesn't want federal
officers in portland he ought to do his
job
yeah in court papers that were filed
over the weekend apparently
federal government says at least 50
thousand dollars worth of damage has
been done
to the hatfield courthouse there in
portland not only in
vandalism and graffiti but also the
constant fires that they seem to start
every night
senator i we want you to try to
decipher for us if you would what
congressman jerry nadler
uh said on a twitter video with a
journalist by the name of austin
fletcher because he was asked about
violence and antifa
and he called it a myth watch this
there's violence across the whole
country do you just about the monster
mantiva
that's happening in portland right now
that's right that's that's a myth
that's being spread only in washington
d.c about antifa in portland
yes sir there's there's videos
everywhere online there's fires and
riots they're throwing
fireworks at uh federal officers dhs is
there
look online it gets crazy mr nadler
so senator i can't tell if he is
referring to the part of the sentence
where
the reporter says there's violence
across the whole country
is he calling that a myth or is he
calling the fact that antifa
is in portland a myth
well jared and adler denying antifa is
in portland as kind of like baghdad bob
denying there were american tanks in
baghdad back in the day i mean you could
just look at the videos that have been
posted in recent weeks i mean
people are carrying the flag of antifa
and wearing t-shirts and spray painting
it
on buildings obviously that's not the
only people on the streets in portland
but there's no question
that there are professional instigators
and agitators on the streets in portland
who are trying to stir up
violence it's a sad situation that
people who want to protest peacefully or
demonstrate for any cause
can't do so without these instigators
and agitators trying to infiltrate their
protests and use them for their own
purposes
so the republicans are set to unveil the
coronavirus bill
which will include 1200 in stimulus
checks liability protections for
businesses and schools
what else can we expect
well ainsley i don't want to speculate
on the legislation since it's not
revealed yet but i want to stress that
in
march we did not know much about this
virus we did not know about the kind of
impact it was going to have that's why
we unanimously passed the cares act
i would not have viewed that at the time
as
a recovery bill or cert or even a
stimulus bill
it was a survival bill but now that we
know so much more about
this virus and its impact now that we
know about the economic impacts it had
we really need to have a bill that is
much more
finely targeted and calibrated towards
the needs that we see today
like helping our schools and colleges
and universities and businesses get open
by protecting them
from ambulance chasing trial lawyers or
helping our doctors and hospitals and
clinics
get the supplies that they need to
ensure
that we are testing insufficient speed
and volume
and to focus aid on where it's truly
needed
on some of those industries and
businesses that are
most heavily impacted that haven't been
able to get to work people who are still
out of work
through no fault of their own through
the fault only of the chinese communist
party so
that's what i expect you'll see in the
bill today and that's where our focus
will be
in the days ahead senator tom cotton you
also in the eye of the storm you like to
take on high
red hot issues including the 1619
project and here's part of your
interview with the arkansas
democratic gazette quote we have to
study the history of slavery and its
role and impact on the development of
our country because otherwise we can't
understand our country
as the founders founding fathers said it
was the necessary evil upon which the
union was built
but the union was built in a way as
lincoln said to put slavery on the
course to ultimate extinction
some say that was insensitive
well that is fake news brian that's not
what i said what i said is that many
founders
believed that only with the union and
the constitution
could we put slavery on the path to its
ultimate extinction
that's exactly what lincoln said of
course slavery is a
evil institution in all its forms at all
times
in america's past or around the world
today but the fundamental moral
principle
of america is right there in the
declaration all men are created equal
and the history of america is the long
and sometimes difficult
struggle to live up to that principle
that's a history we ought to be proud of
not the historical revisionism of the
1619 project
which wants to indoctrinate america's
kids and teach them to hate america to
believe that america was founded
not on human freedom but on racism to
think that slavery was not
an aberration but the true heart of
america that's why leading historians
like james mcpherson or gordon wood have
debunked the 16-19 project that's why
i've introduced legislation to ensure
that federal tax dollars don't go to
teaching it
the new york times should not be
teaching american history to our kids
senator before you go today marks 99
days
before the election day what is the
state of the race right now
well i think it's a close race in the
presidential campaign and senate
campaigns as well
and the american people are going to be
asking who is going to be best equipped
to help get the economy back on its feet
who is going to protect
our communities from the violence we see
in the streets who's going to protect
this nation from the threat of the
chinese communist party and other
threats abroad
and as we head down the home stretch of
this campaign i think that they'll
conclude that it's the president
and the republican party senator thank
you for being with us
[Music]
thank you all